gérard vestiaires bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france pour décrypter
analyser avec nous cette réunion
aujourd'hui à moscou sur l'afghanistan
une réunion sans les etats-unis qui ont
annoncé hier qu'ils ne participeraient
pas à ces pourparlers ils évoquent des
raisons logistiques et ce juste après la
démission de l'émissaire américain en
afghanistan ce sont les seules raisons
écoutez il ré au moins une troisième
c'est qu'il y ait eu des rencontres
entre les talibans et les états unis à à
doha il y a dix jours il y a eu d'être
une rencontre entre les taliban et
l'europe l'union européenne à doha il y
a dix jours donc effectivement on a eu
des discussions étaient très nombreuses
au sujet de l'afghanistan est ce qui est
intéressant de noter c'est que avant la
reprise des de l'afghanistan par les
talibans l'afghanistan était un conflit
international a donc avec la présence
américaine de leurs alliés et de l'otan
et maintenant il y à une beaucoup plus
grande implication régionale
la chine est bien sûr appliqué avec eux
75 km de frontières avec l'afghanistan
le pakistan au combien et puis bien sûr
la russie n'est pas très loin donc en
passe de cheveux l'international aux
régionales alors justement ce sont ces
trois pays qui vont échanger aujourd'hui
il va falloir qu'il trouve une position
commune ça va être uniquement sur les
questions de sécurité et d'humanitaire
je crois qu'il ya troisième chapitre ce
qui est celui de l'économique et donc ça
ça va pas être très simple parce que le
budget de l'afghanistan est à 170
milliards de dollars et donc on arrive à
une situation de grande désorganisation
du pays et à je crois qu'il faut
s'attendre à des difficultés encore plus
profonde avec l'afghanistan ah parce que
les talibans ont construit leur image
leur réputation et leur un mouvement de
reprise en s'appuyant sur la justice et
l'ordre
la sécurité est donc on voit que avec
les thématiques développées vous aviez
des femmes il ya beaucoup d'injustice en
privant les femmes de travail et donc de
revenus cela déséquilibre l'économie du
pays et avec ce vous vous avez présenté
au cernant l'action de l'état ni à
l'afghanistan passe kull dans la
sécurité donc les deux buts et un fort
de détection sont actuellement attaqué à
part leur propre comportement et par les
attaques de l'état islamique alors
justement l'autre le président russe
vladimir poutine hier dans s'est
inquiétée vendredi pardon a des
ambitions et d'efforts sein du groupe
djihadiste état islamique en afghanistan
l'asie et des régions russes heskey
pourrait être menacée par ses ambitions
jihadistes
écoutez a indirectement je pense que le
la vision de l'état islamique et
d'essayer d'un point de vue
stratégique de transformer l'émirat
islamique d'afghanistan en khalifa n'est
ce pas dont deux de remodeler ce qui a
été fait avec l'irak et la syrie il y à
il ya sept ans maintenant et est ce qui
risque de se passer effectivement c'est
que s'il ya une déstabilisation à en
afghanistan et bien par
ricochet par rebond si vous voulez il y
aura forcément des tensions dans les
communautés musulmanes des pays
d'alentour et il y a le caucase sud
russe donc il y à là le daghestan il y à
la tchétchénie lyall ingouchie voyez
vous donc des territoires russes à total
pratiquement majorité d'avoir population
est musulmane donc la russie a raison de
s'inquiéter parce que par ricochet il
peut y avoir une tension nouvelle dans
la communauté musulmane est donc dans
les mouvements djihadistes locaux une
solution niger est telle que j'ai exclu
aujourd'hui
oui elle n'a pas donné donc il y a dans
les années 70 n'est ce pas et 80 les
résultats escomptés elle n'a pas donné
dans les années 2000 2020 les résultats
escomptés donc il n'y a pas de solution
militaire il y a une c'est qu une
solution sécuritaire
parce que c'est effectivement la
difficulté de trouver les cellules
dormantes n'est ce pas de l'état
islamique à vladimir poutine a indiqué
il ya quelques jours que les services de
renseignement russes voyez beaucoup
d'arrivées où beaucoup en tout cas
certain nombre d'arrivées de syriens et
irakiens préparer au combat en
afghanistan
donc là c'est vraiment une préoccupation
sécuritaire première pour la stabilité
de la région et le deuxième volet c'est
le volet économique alors moi je crains
beaucoup la déstabilisation à de
l'économie afghane par les talibans et
du coup quelles sont les positions
communes que pourrait adopter la russie
la chine et le pakistan
d'écouté je crois qu'il faut d'abord
avoir une stabilisation à politique à
mais cela ce n'est pas forcément facile
à obtenir parce qu'il ya des positions
idéologiques utah libanais de faire un
gouvernement inclusif n'est pas
forcément dans les dossiers de moscou ou
de pékin a mais il faut impérativement
qu'il y ait une surveillance accrue des
frontières afghane ça c'est absolument
crucial pour que effectivement des
moudjahidine des combattants venant de
l'extérieur ne se répande pas dans le
pays car si vous regardez la carte il ya
eu les attentats monstrueux à l'aéroport
de kaboul menés par l'état islamique il
y a eu la main là l'attentât la mosquée
de koundouz ce nom qui est dans
l'extrême nord de l'afghanistan est
récemment devenu à 48 heures attends
d'art dans l'extrême sud donc capital
extrême nord extrême sud il y à un
message de l'état islamique qui dit nous
sommes partout merci beaucoup gérard
vestiaire pour autre éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
analyste géopolitique chercheur associé
à la febo fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté merci